LARRY ARNN: There's a
lot in the ethics that's
Goldilocks argument.
Not too hot, not too
cold, just right,
and how do you make a rule
to tell which is which?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What is character?
SPEAKER 1: It's the state
of the soul that arises
from the choices one makes.
LARRY ARNN: State of the soul
that arises from the choices
that you make.
OK, so we're going to try to
figure out how that works,
and to do that,
we're going to begin
with the beginning of
Book two of the ethics,
and if somebody reads
the first paragraph,
there's some cool
stuff in there.
SPEAKER 2: Now, since virtue
is of two sorts, one pertaining
to thinking and the
other to character,
excellence of thinking
is, for the most part,
both in its coming to
be and in its growth
a result of teaching
for which reason
it has a need of
experience and time,
while excellence
of character comes
into being as a consequence
of habit on account
of which it even gets its
name by a small inflection
from habit.
LARRY ARNN: How do you
make a good choice?
No simple answer, but
one thing is the motive.
You have to do it to do
the right thing, especially
the beautiful thing.
You also have to estimate
the circumstances.
Well, an act is courageous if
it's done for the beautiful,
unless it's grossly foolish.
You can imagine some movie
where some soldier stands
up and charges a whole army
of tanks and gets blown away
and that's brave in one
way, but in another way,
it's ridiculous.
So you don't want to
do that, so there's
a whole bunch of things
that make for a good choice,
but the point he's
making here is
that you go from
habit to character
by making choices
and making them well,
and that's what changes you.
And if we don't
make good choices,
it will violate our
nature, but it's not
natural in the same
sense as our growing
or as an oak tree
growing is natural.
The realm of volition in
which human beings live
is all important.
You can take 1,000 examples,
they're everywhere.
But if you commit vicious acts
often, abuse people, which
will turn you into a tyrant and
you'll be hated and unhappy,
drink to excess, turn you
into a drunk, be unhappy,
you can do those things.
Then you're harming your
nature, whereas if you
make good choices, you
accord more completely
with your nature.
But don't mistake
that you are not
an agent in the doing of it.
There's a lot in the ethics
that Goldilocks argument.
Not too hot, not too
cold, just right.
Not too hard, not too soft, and
that's an interesting problem,
because how do you make a
rule to tell which is which?
How do you know,
and the answer is,
there isn't any rule
that you can make.
In this case of
training, it's not
too hard to know that if you
run until you're exhausted
and your shins hurt and
you can't run anymore,
then you've run too much.
And if you don't run
enough and you're
exhausted when you start
and you can't keep up,
you haven't trained enough.
Take moderation.
There isn't any iron rule.
You're seeking a right amount.
Indeed, it's the business of
life to seek the right amount,
and there's all these obstacles
and temptations and confusions
that are in the way, but
if you think about it
and you keep your soul in order
and you keep your direction,
your attitude right, then
you'll make better choices,
and Aristotle is saying that's
how you hone in on this.
And another point to understand
is it gets easier while you go.
Is school easier than
when you started?
Yeah, you probably showed
up, wow, this is awful.
Can't do this.
Now you can't, it's just hard.
So you see what you've gained.
You have a better soul
than you had before.
So that point then is don't
underestimate what you know,
and the whole question of choice
is going to hang on this thing
that, in your heart
of hearts, you know.
And if you choose against
that consistently,
that is the only way
to silence that voice.
And if you listen to that
voice, it will become strong
and it will drown
out everything else.
That is the specific action
of character building.
That's what it does.
I'm Larry Arnn, president
of Hillsdale College.
You will find if you look
at our online courses
that they cover the whole
range of human learning,
all the high and fundamental
things everyone needs to know.
They are free,
because we have always
wished to provide sound
learning to anyone
who wishes to have it.